-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You made it.
Thank you for watching.
Thanks for being here.
Well, guys,
this is very exciting.
Tomorrow is
the official start of summer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tomorrow.
I love summer,
although I could have done
without this on my subway ride
to work today.
A guy handed me sunscreen and
asked if I would do his back.
I go --
[ Laughter ]
Here's some good news.
Starting tomorrow,
COVID vaccine shots will be
available to kids 5 and under.
Yeah, that's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's -- That's right, kiddos.
No more excuses.
Time to head back to the office
like the rest of us.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, kids can finally get
vaccinated against COVID.
Meanwhile,
Chuck E. Cheese was like,
[ Puffs cigarette ] "I still
wouldn't touch that ball pit."
[ Coughing ]
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Kids as young as 6 months
can get Pfizer's
three-dose vaccine.
Yep, every parents dream --
taking their kid
three times in a row
to get a shot.
[ Laughter ]
Three shots.
Right now, parents are like,
"What the hell?
Might as well
get their ears pierced, too."
[ Laughter ]
Well, everyone's
been talking about this.
Over the weekend,
President Biden
was on a bike ride...
[ Laughter ]
I don't even need to do a joke.
-Yeah.
-He's going for a bike ride
near his beach house in Delaware
when he took a little spill.
Here, check this out,
if you haven't seen it.
[ Cheers ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba ]
[ Cymbals crash ]
Poor Biden.
Even his bike was like,
"I'm sorry, but I can
no longer support you."
[ Laughter ]
If you want to see
that clip again,
it's airing on a 24-hour loop
on Fox News.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's --
it's shocking.
Not the fall, that Biden looks
kind of good in bike shorts.
That's what I thought.
I go, "Interesting."
That's right, Biden fell
and everyone has jokes,
but no one ever talks about how
good he used to be on a bike.
Do you guys remember this video?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
They never show that.
I mean, that was back --
that was back before --
-Wow!
-That was back before
you had toe clips or whatever.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Penny-farthing.
-Yeah.
Speaking of the President,
according to a recent poll,
most Americans do not want Biden
or former President Trump
to run again in 2024.
Yeah, in two years, America is
gonna walk into a voting booth
like, "Uh, can we choose
'None of the above'?
What are we --"
[ Laughter ]
I think we're at the point now
where 2024 is just gonna be
holograms of JFK and Reagan.
You go...
[ Laughter ]
It's a tough choice.
People are like,
"Do I want a guy
who can't ride a bike
or a guy who can't
walk down a ramp?
I don't know which --"
[ Laughter ]
Well, on Saturday,
Trump held a rally in Memphis,
and he said pretty much
what you'd expect.
So, instead of showing
the same clips
you've seen a million times,
it's time
for another installment of
"Trump With No Context."
Enjoy.
♪♪
Shyeah!
Ahhh!
[ Grunts ]
Unnhhh!
Unh!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-You guys see this?
Apparently, HBO is working on
a "Game of Thrones" spinoff
series based around Jon Snow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm pretty sure
that already exists.
It's called "Game of Thrones."
Am I wrong?
[ Laughter ]
That would be like NBC
creating a "Seinfeld" spinoff
based on Jerry.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, this is exciting.
A new trailer for the next
"Fast & Furious" sequel
just came out,
and I gotta say,
it looks pretty intense.
Check this out.
[ Engines revving ]
-This summer,
fasten your seatbelts
because the family
is getting back together
for one more epic ride.
[ Laughter ]
"Fast & Furious X:
Joe-Kyo Drift."
[ Bike bell rings ]
Presented in partnership
with Metamucil.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Joe-Kyo Drift."
-"Joe-Kyo."
-[ Laughs ]
"Joe-Kyo Drift."
Yeah.
-"Joe-Kyo Drift."
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
-Hey, guys, get this.
I heard about a guy
who was addicted to Pepsi
and said he drank
30 cans a day for 20 years.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Yeah, asked what
finally made him stop, he said,
"I tried a Coke."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he's totally fine, except
if you shake him, he explodes.
[ Laughter ]
Ladies and gentlemen, I read
that, according to a new poll,
Americans only feel relaxed
for about 40 minutes a day.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
I thought we'd try
to get that up to 41
by sharing some
relaxing thoughts, right now,
during this show.
Can I get some music, please?
[ Soft music plays ]
[ Clears throat ]
Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
Hey.
No one remembers
that you had bangs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
When your friends
make a new group chat,
they type in your name first.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Every day, your mailman's like,
"Oh, my God.
This is the most mail
I've ever seen!"
[ Laughter ]
You're not a wimp for peeling
off the pudding skin.
That stuff's gross.
[ Laughter and applause ]
If he met you, Channing Tatum
would probably like you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That e-mail that you've been
meaning to send for two years,
when you finally send it,
it'll be that much more special.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Last night at dinner,
you said something so funny,
the waiter
told the chef about it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Nobody flosses.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Everyone's knees crack a little
when they kneel.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
The cooler you are,
the louder they crunch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally, you look great
in that first selfie.
There's no need
to take any more.
[ Laughter ]
You nailed it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
I feel better.
I feel more relaxed.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Well, it was a crazy travel
weekend all over the world.
And I saw that there was
a luggage malfunction
at the London Heathrow Airport
that created a bit of a backup.
If you haven't seen this,
take a look at this.
-Oh!
-Wow.
-It's odd when an airline
loses your baggage
but also knows
exactly where it is.
[ Laughter ]
One woman said,
"That's why I tie
a little red ribbon on my bag."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, T.J.Maxx is like,
"Looks fine to us.
That looks cool.
That's normal."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, it's time
for our latest installment
of "Tonight Show" Polls.
Here we go,
ladies and gentlemen.
-♪ "Tonight Show Polls" ♪
Now this first poll asked...
[ Cheers and applause ]
This next poll asked...
And there you go. Alright.
[ Laughter and applause ]
No. We're good.
This next poll asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This next poll said...
"I'm a genius."
This next one asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This last poll asked...
That's all the time we have
for "Tonight Show Polls."